IN OTHER WORDS, THEIR SAFETY HAS
BEEN FULLY REIMAGINED.
MARK MCCLOSKEY JOINS US TONIGHT.
MARK, THANKS MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO BEFORE I ASK YOU ABOUT HOW
YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS TO REIMAGINE
PUBLIC SAFETY YOU BEEN SUBJECTED
TO, TELL US SPECIFICALLY WHAT
HAPPEN WHEN THE POLICE VISITED
YOUR HOME RECENTLY.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE POLICE
WERE REALLY VERY PROFESSIONAL
AND VERY NICE.
THEY COPS THAT CAME OUT TO ISSUE
THE SEARCH WARRANT EN MASSE,
THEY WERE ALMOST APOLOGETIC.
THEY DIDN’T WANT TO HAVE TO BE
THERE.
THEY WERE DOING THEIR JOB.
PATTY WANTED TO TAKE A PICTURE
TO DOCUMENT IT AND SHE ASKED IF
THEY WOULDN’T MIND FACING AWAY
FROM THE CAMERA SO THAT PEOPLE
WOULDN’T GET MAD AT THEM IF
THEIR FACES WERE SHOWN ON TV.
THEY ALL DID SO.
THEY UNFORTUNATE ARE STUCK
BETWEEN A CIRCUIT ATTORNEY THAT
WANTS TO PROSECUTE US IN THEIR
OWN BELIEF THAT WE DID
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING WRONG.
>> Tucker: IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING, I MEAN, POLICE
DEPARTMENT’S ARE STRUCTURED
ALONG THE LINES OF THE MILITARY.
THEY DON’T MAKE INDEPENDENT.
THEY ARE TOLD WHAT TO TO DO AND
THEY DO IT.
THEY DIDN’T MAKE THIS DECISION
INDEPENDENTLY BUT YOU STILL CAN
ESCAPE THE CONTRAST OF WHAT
HAPPENED THE NIGHT THE MOB CAME
TO YOUR HOME AND YOU CALL THE
POLICE AND THEY DIDN’T, AND THEN
THEY COME AT THE COMMAND OF THE
PROSECUTING ATTORNEY LATER TO
TAKE THE DEFEND YOURSELF.
IS THAT WHAT POLICE ARE FOR, DO
YOU THINK?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, AND MY
ATTORNEY ADVISED ME NOT TO BE ON
THE SHOW TONIGHT BECAUSE THE
RUMOR IS THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
INDICTED SHORTLY.
HAVING SAID THAT, THIS IS THE
SAME CIRCUIT ATTORNEY THAT
REALLY 35 OF THE PROTESTERS THAT
TORCHED AND LOOTED IN DOWNTOWN
ST. LOUIS BUT NOW SHE WANTS TO
INDICT ME.
I DIDN’T SHOOT ANYBODY.
I JUST HELD MY GROUND,
PROTECTING MY HOUSE, AND I’M
SITTING HERE ON TELEVISION
TONIGHT INSTEAD OF DEAD OR
PUTTING OUT THE SMOLDERING
EMBERS OF MY HOME.
>> Tucker: SO I MEAN, YOUR
STRATEGY IN RESPONSE TO ALL THIS
SEEMS TO BE STAYING SILENT
DOESN’T GET TO ANYTHING,
OBVIOUSLY.
IF YOU JUST RETREATED INTO YOUR
HOUSE, IT PROBABLY WOULD BE
BURNED TO THE GROUND, AS YOU
JUST SAID.
BUT IS THAT HOW SOCIETY SHOULD
FUNCTION?
I MEAN, SHOULDN’T SOMEONE IN
AUTHORITY IN THE STATE OF
MISSOURI BE COMING TO YOUR AID
RIGHT ABOUT NOW?
>> YOU KNOW, THE WAY I VIEW IT
IS, WHEN YOU HAVE CERTAIN
ELEMENTS OF SOCIETY ENCOURAGING
VIOLENCE, AT THE SAME TIME
ASKING THE POLICE TO STAND DOWN,
WHAT’S THE ONLY POSSIBLE RESULT?
THE ONLY POSSIBLE SOLUTION IS
FOR INDIVIDUAL CITIZENS TO STAND
UP AND DEFEND THEMSELVES.
I’M AFRAID THAT WHAT’S BEING
PROMOTED IS CAUSING CITIZENS TO
STAND UP AND DEFEND THEMSELVES
SO THEY CAN BE ABUSED THE WAY WE
HAVE BEEN.
>> Tucker: I DON’T THINK
THERE’S ANY DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
I DON’T THINK THERE’S A
HOMEOWNER IN AMERICA WANTS TO
DEFEND HIS OWN HOME WITH A GUN.
THAT SOMETHING YOU DO IF YOU
HAVE NO CHOICE.
YOU’D MUCH RATHER THE POLICE
CAME AND TOOK THE RISK FOR YOU.
THAT’S WHY YOU PAY THEM BUT THEY
WANT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE MEDIA
RESPONSE?
YOU ARE LECTURED ON ANOTHER
CHANNEL BY A GUY WHO’S
THREATENED VIOLENCE AGAINST
PEOPLE FOR GETTING IN HIS SPACE
AND YET HE DRESSED YOU DOWN FOR
DEFENDING YOUR HOME.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> THE TRADITIONAL MEDIA IS
RIGHT BEHIND THE MOB.
WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO USE THAT
WORD ANYMORE.
A LOUD CROWD OF ANGRY PEOPLE AND
THEY ARE SUPPORTING THESE
ENTITIES WHICH ARE FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING MARXIST AND OPPOSE
EVERY THING I STAND BORN I HOLD
DEAR.
WE HAVE GOTTEN TREMENDOUS
SUPPORT FROM ORDINARY PEOPLE.
MY PHONES IN MY EMAILS ARE AT
ABOUT 90% POSITIVE.
WE HAVE GOTTEN CALLS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
I GOT A NICE LETTER FROM A LADY
IN IRELAND CONGRATULATED US FOR
TAKING A STAND AGAINST VIOLENCE
AND SO I THINK THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF AMERICANS WISH
THEY COULD DO SOMETHING.
THE PROBLEM IS IF NOBODY STANDS
UP AND SUPPORTS THEM, IF THE
MEDIA BLASTS THEM, I’M
SELF-EMPLOYED.
I OWN MY OWN LAW FIRM.
WHAT IF I WAS AN EMPLOYEE
SOMEWHERE?
IF I DID WHAT I DID AND I WAS AN
EMPLOYEE OF ANYBODY ELSE, I
WOULD HAVE BEEN CANNED THE NEXT
DAY.
MY FAMILY WOULD’VE BEEN CANNED.
NO ONE WOULD EVER GET A JOB
AGAIN.
THIS IS THE KIND OF SOCIAL
PRESSURE THAT KEEPS PEOPLE FROM
STANDING UP AND DEFENDING
THEMSELVES AND I THINK IT’S TIME
FOR PEOPLE TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
STAND.
ACTUALLY STAND UP AND HAVE SOME
RISK.
PATRICK HENRY SAID GIVE ME
LIBERTY OR GIVE ME DEATH AND NOW
EVERYBODY SO AFRAID OF LOSING
THEIR JOB.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU’RE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
SLOGANS LIKE THAT ARE
MEANINGLESS AND LESS PEOPLE IN
UP TO DEFEND THE COUNTRY.
MARK MCCLOSKEY, WHO HAS DEFENDED